this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you it's always a pleasure to be
among the soil scientists and
particularly Tony who was very generous
with his time in teaching us about his
work as a scientists many years ago one
of my former students interviewed Tony
and that interview was edited into
something that we call an oral history
profile and it was included in that 2010
book that Tony mentioned and I'll be
quoting you in a few minutes so um I am
as some of you may be fairly agitated
right now and angry and worried not just
about what happened in the election but
about deeper issues and questions that
have to do with the state of our society
how well how divided we are and how well
or how poorly we understand each other
how well or how poorly we listen to each
other um it's not irrelevant for me to
say that at the beginning of this
session because the the theme or topic
or idea of civic science is very much
centered on relationships between
scientists and non-scientists that
include a lot of listening and a lot of
understanding and a lot of dealing with
difference mmm so this is a topic that I
have been working on for a number of
years I am I've got as most of us do way
too many balls in the air and so things
proceed more slowly than they should but
I we had an NSF workshop on this theme
as Tony mentioned in 2014 or working on
both an essay and a book project related
to this theme of civic science the theme
resonates across a lot of my work so
it's it's something that isn't just
contained
there I feel rather strangely double
miked here so I don't feel like I'm on
an interrogation stage or something and
then I see this one person sitting there
Geneva like the judge sitting sitting in
front of the court so civic science is a
term like a lot of terms we hear about
that first of all it has a it has a
history of us as a specific term part of
its genealogy is that it was first
actually maybe first probably not first
but maybe first used in 1996 in a talk
that Neil Lane gave when he was the
director of NSF and he was speaking to a
meeting of the american association for
the advancement of science and talking
about the role of science and scientists
in society and he used the term civic
science to talk about basically the the
idea that scientists should be
communicating to the public more
frequently they should be taking more
time to be helping the public understand
science they should be taking more time
to share the results of science to be
bringing scientific knowledge and ideas
to the public at all kinds of variety of
ways not just panels in Washington DC
not just media interviews but in
community settings as well mmm that is
not what i mean by civic science the
definition that he gave is not it Oh
Civic science is also not citizen
science the way I'm talking about it
it's not applied research it's not
activist science it's not it's there's
all kinds of turns out there it's none
of those so I want to share a bit about
how I have been coming to find and
discover this idea of civic science
my work and how I've been trying to make
sense of it and some of the questions I
have about it I'm sorry to be relying on
on notes a lot here but I want to be
careful and as i mentioned i'm fairly
agitated right now and suffering from
lack of sleep my wife is a state
legislator she was just reacted to her
seventh term the new york state assembly
so I was up all night the other night
and apologies for my own trouble so
civic science is not a dreamy
theoretical thing that some egghead
professor like me and development
sociology made up and is trying to you
know sell to two people it's not that
it's a discovery it's a way of naming a
discovery out of my own research out of
other people's research I'm primarily a
historian but I come to the work of
history with a lot of tools from a
variety of disciplines i'anson
technology studies development sociology
narrative in Korean analysis civic
studies political theory public
philosophy I draw from all of those in
my historical work mmm civic science is
something that is deeply rooted in land
grant colleges of agriculture including
this one very much so but it is not
contained to those colleges as a
historical trajectory just one of the
things that has happened recently in the
in the literature's that I pay attention
to historian from Harvard named Andrew
Jewett is published a book recently that
I wrote a review for for a journal it's
called science democracy in the American
University from the Civil War to the
Cold War what he does in this book is he
traces what he refers to as a history of
scientific Democrats that's his turn
from the Civil War to the Cold War and
what he's tracing is something that is
not there's not a lot of awareness of a
whole variety of places and there's a
lot of critique of and push back again
what he's tracing is this history of
thinking and work about how democracy
sorry how science the methods and
processes of science have huge deep
cultural and political significance and
and possibilities and so there were a
lot of people who thinking these are
mostly people in fields like political
theory and philosophy and psychology and
those kinds of fields a lot of people
were were deeply convinced that if we
could spread scientific the what they
people like John do is do we variously
referred to as the scientific spirit or
the scientific morale Liberty High
Bailey wrote about this which I'll come
back to if we could spread that if
people could could learn to see the
world using some of the methods and
processes of Sciences this would have
huge transformational implications for
our culture and ones that are aligned
with what we usually referred to as
democracy and you know most of you in
this room i'm assuming our scientists we
can think about this you do experiments
you make them visible in public what you
did what you found and it's up for
debate other people can try and see if
they find the same thing or something
different there's real deep democratic
possibilities in that kind of thing it
comes out of the whole notion of who
gets to create knowledge well based on
the work of science anybody who can
learn these methods and processes can
take part in that it doesn't come just
from the church or a dog love or the
government or the King you know these
are big historical things I'm talking
about here anyway there's so there's
this long tradition of that so civic
science is connected to that as I'll
talk about a little more clearly in a
minute at the at the center of civic
science as an idea the way I'm
understanding it is that it represents a
particular way of answering a set of
normative questions about the roles
responsibilities purposes and war
work of scientists and scientific
institutions like universities in the
civic sphere or in civic or public life
it's about the Nate that questions about
the nature of the relationship between
scientists and non-scientists
particularly in societies that that
strive to be or want to be democratic so
civic science represents a way of
answering these questions so it's
important to note normative questions
are not empirical questions they're not
about what is or what has been or what
could be they use this troubling word in
the Academy we have a lot of problems
with this word the word is should Civic
science represents a way of answering a
set of questions by taking up by taking
the word should and answering it not
just inferior ideas but in practice in
the world so the prevailing way of
answering this bundle of questions about
the role in relationship between science
and non scientists and science in the
public sphere the the prevailing way of
understanding that is that the it's
basically an expert client relationship
science scientists scientists scientific
institutions produce stuff which is
communicated out to the world and they
produce stuff from a place of detachment
from that world and why is this this is
to use the fancy academic words there's
an epistemological reason for this
because one of the most fundamental
questions we could take up in a day in
any society is how do we produce
knowledge that people can trust
trustworthy knowledge how do we do that
where do we do that who does that so
there's a whole way of kind of
prevailing sense of well you need a
detached thing that's outside the biased
and messy world of the marketplace and
government and this you can't trust
stuff that comes out of there because
it's going to be self-interested in bias
so you need someplace that's apart from
that where people can pursue work from a
objective disinterested unbiased these
kinds of words people use perspective so
that's the sort of a typical way that we
look at the the set of normative
questions so about what we should do
what our relationship should be our
meaning scientists so civic science as
I've been learning in my research and
work and it have been understanding
coming to understand doesn't dismiss
it's not about dismissing questions of
trustworthiness and of course in a land
grant institution we're not just
interested in trustworthiness we're
instance interested in knowledge people
can trust and use that the use piece is
pretty important so the civic science
tradition that I'm uncovering and try to
understand doesn't dismiss all that it
doesn't say that we that we should never
have people working from a place of
detachment in laboratories on campuses
up on hills like Cornell here the
classic ivory tower it doesn't say we
shouldn't have that what I'm finding in
my own work and this is definitely
influenced by my own perspective which I
need to be transparent about the fancy
word for that is reflexive to be
reflexive is to be conscious of your own
biases and political views and and to be
candid about those and I definitely have
them and that'll come out in a minute so
the tradition that I'm uncovering
doesn't reject all of that what it does
and the best way to understand it is it
expands and broadens the ground and the
set of possibilities for how to be a
scientist for you're not it means that
science scientists don't always have to
be detached in laboratories up on hills
that sometimes you can be there and you
can be out in the and telling this
people in this room of this
this is nothing new this is what people
have done in this college for over a
hundred years but not everybody thinks
about that or understands that what's
important about Civic science I think
which moves us to the place of deep deep
deep complexity way beyond what I'm
going to be able to do here with you
both because of time and and other
issues it's important about it is that
it doesn't just expand these
possibilities of how to do work it also
opens up very distinctive kinds of
promise promises possible of meaning and
significance of the work and in doing
that it opens up very distinctive kinds
of challenges and problems so what I
want to do today hopefully in enough
time for us to have some interaction
because I could go on for way too long
in my agitated state I want to I want to
begin with a couple of historical
artifacts from our own college here at
Cornell brief historical artifacts then
I want to very briefly and very
superficially start taking up the task
of interpreting those artifacts this is
the research of that I do as a scholar
so i'm working with original material
and data and as a historian I don't just
paste and copy that data I have to
position it in a narrative position it
in a in an essay that interprets the
meaning and significance of these
artifacts have to put them in context
and I have to use tools to be able to do
that so I want to I want to very briefly
sort of show you sort of the inside it's
like walking into my lab in some ways
it's like the the inside nuts and bolts
of how we work with this of this
material thinking of these artifacts
like you would think of plant material
or poor soil samples then I want to turn
to the issue of actual practice of civic
science in contemporary times this is
what I'm going to quote you
I'm going to quote somebody else more
than I'm going to quote you I'll save
you and then I want to conclude by just
naming some of the challenges and
questions that arise for me and thinking
about this theme and before I plunge
into this I'll say that I am approaching
and doing this work in many ways out of
a sense of urgent necessity because I
think institutions like this are in
trouble and I think our communities and
our society is in trouble and beyond the
trouble I think there are enormous
incredible possibilities that are
untapped positive possibilities that
Civic science I think has a big role to
play in opening up both in dealing with
troubles but also in opening up
possibilities so here are the artifacts
I'm just these are two things I found in
my historical research the little little
data points through a moment in time so
the first one actually is from 1920 to
the former director of Cornell
Cooperative Extension a man named
Maurice chase burritt MC birotte we were
up in a farm in western New York
graduate of Cornell it's called the
County agent and the Farm Bureau a real
barn Buster barn burner kind of title
right whale want to read this was 19 22
so it was very pretty shortly after the
farm bureau was created we know the
first one was in New York and broome
county and shortly after 1914 less than
10 years after when the National
extension system was created and this
County agent thing was it was a big deal
he this guy went on I don't know if
anybody knows who he was but he had all
kinds of roles in New York agriculture
and state and United States policy mmm
so at the end of this book he he
actually didn't write this here's not to
go to it he says at the very the last
two pages he said summarizing then the
ideal expressed
this volume for the Farm Bureau movement
may be put in the form of this brief
Creed and then he lays out what he calls
a farm bureau Creed so here are four
sentences from that Creed we believe in
self-help for ourselves our community
our country in our own abilities well
developed and properly supported to
solve our own problems and in local and
voluntary leadership and here the next
three sentences we believe in a program
a definite carefully considered plan of
work local and conception and in
character which looks toward the
solution of the problems which are vital
to the welfare of the farm and the home
this plan of action for the organization
should be made at home by those most
concerned but with the best expert
advice and assistance and then the last
sentence we believe in a partnership
between farmers and the public
agricultural agencies between practice
and science for the working out of this
program so these are sentences about
self-help that there's a fierce voice of
independence of you damn well better
respect us because we're going to solve
our own problems but we want to be in
some kind of relationship best assistant
assistance best expert advice and
assistance they're talking about a
partnership so here's the next little
artifact in 1949 the history of Cornell
Cooperative Extension was published it
was called written by Ruby green Smith
who spent three decades as the home
bureau leader in the state of New York
and she gave it the very wonderful title
the people's colleges and this is just
one little this is like a 600-page book
which Cornell University Press has just
republished in the past few years I
wrote the preface for the new edition
it's easily available very interesting
history so here's a passage here's a
little passage from that as another
artifact I'm just pulling this out of
one of these it's on page 544 on
Facebook all right here it is extension
workers need to have faith in spiritual
values and to recognize the human
relationships that contribute to what
the ancient Greeks called the good life
they should believe that in the kinds of
homes farms and industries which are the
goals of extension service man cannot
live by bread alone that it is not
enough for people to have food shelter
and clothing that they aspire also to
find appreciation respect for
individuality and human dignity
affection ideals and opportunities these
are the satisfactions that belong to
democratic living
so as a historian I I have I came into
my work being fascinated with these land
grant colleges because I was deeply
interested in the question of what is
the relationship between higher
education these colleges and
universities and the public and
communities and what's which quickly
goes to the place of what are we
supposed to be doing what are we what
are these institutions do what's our
work and as I've been doing this
research now for 20 years I've been
finding this really these really
interesting voices that you hear in
these two passages from Cornell they're
not speaking about the kind of thing we
would expect to be hearing about
certainly not spiritual issues about the
extension agent or the Extension Service
what is going on in these passages so
moving now to the next thing I said I
was going to talk about how do we
interpret the meaning and significance
of those two artifacts that I just
showed you as discoveries from my work
and you know I have hundreds and
hundreds of other other discoveries like
this the sort of pattern of a way of
thinking of things being said so as I
mentioned this pushes us in in really
complex territory because in order to
interpret these kinds of passages not
only do we have to put them in their
context of their time and place not only
do we have to put them in some kind of
historical trajectory we have we need
tools just like you need tools to in
those of you or soil scientists to do
your analysis and work and so we use
tools in in the field that I work in
that basically as a historical
sociologist and that sort of place in
the development sociology field we as
conceptual and theoretical tools and
frameworks to make sense of these things
in addition to the historical tools
and the other part of the complexity of
course here is that we're not just
dealing with determining what happened
it's back to the empirical versus
normative we're not just determining
what this person said this thing in this
year we have to work with trying to
understand what were they trying to
argue what what is the cultural
significance the larger social political
significance of what they were saying we
have to we have to engage in those kinds
of things this gets us in all kinds of
trouble as you might imagine because we
then engage in all the debates about
difference that that people have about
the answer to normative questions of
what we should do what we should not do
so as I said I sparing you all the
complex details of the fine grain
nuanced and jargon Laden material that i
would have to open up to to talk about
these conceptual and theoretical frames
I want to just do something quickly to
sort of it as part of the work of making
sense of those artifacts part of it
includes going back in history because
we have to situate it in a historical
trajectory so I want to go back and then
I want to go to the present before I
conclude with with sort of questions and
concerns out of this so let me go back
first because both of those artifacts in
making sense of them get us to the place
where we're asking questions about
scientists in scientific institutions in
the case of those things we're talking
about Cornell's College of Agriculture
and in those days college of home
economics as well we need to be thinking
we need to be thinking about a
historical trajectory of those
institutions so so as I've done my
historical work one of the things I've
seen moving back to the mid 19th century
is the presence of two
that I think the work of civic science
and the idea of civic science has
brought together and continues to bring
together in its contemporary practice
even though it's mostly unnamed mostly
unfazed so the first one of course has
to do with things that I would assume
many of you are really familiar with and
centered on and to get to this I'm going
to quote Justin Smith moral who as many
of you know was the author of the moral
Act that was passed in 1862 so I have
working on a paper about his vision and
the vision of Jonathan Baldwin Turner
who was a contemporary of his who many
people think is the real father of the
land grant act um so here's a passage
from the speech that Turner gave to
let's see this is 37 Congress so this
was in June of 1862 so here's jet
imagine the floor of Congress 1862
Justin Smith morals on the floor and one
of the things he says is this an
American farming the land is held until
it is robbed of its virtue skimmed of
its cream and then the owner selling his
wasted field to some skinflint neighbor
flies to fresh fields with the foul
purpose to repeat the same sporulation
and thus annual exodus which prevails
over all the older states and even
begins upon the first settlements of the
new states before the remoter borders
have lost sight of the savage as his
language painfully indicates that we
have reached the maximum population or
land will support on the present state
of our agricultural economy we bring
forth new states by the litter and when
we want more like our Norman ancestors
we commit grand larceny and annexed them
this progress seems wonderful but with
it appears the bitter fact that these
new states in half a century a brief
time in the history of the state's
become depleted and stationary this
early maturity is
followed by a sudden berenice the phrase
in these days with soil exhaustion that
was the term that they were using right
so out of this he paints this grim
picture of basically how the land in the
in the US has been totally destroyed by
this horrendously bad farming and then
he issues what I think of as a prophecy
of doom he says should no effort be made
to arrest the deterioration and spoil
ation of the soil in America while all
Europe is wisely striving to teach her
agriculturalists the best means of
hoarding up capital and the lands on
that side of the Atlantic it is easy to
see that we are doomed to be dwarfed in
national importance and not many years
can pass away before our ships will be
laden with grain not on their outward
but homeward voyage then with cheap
bread he says then with cheap bread no
longer peculiar to America our free
institutions may be thought too dear by
those of whom even empires are not
worthy the men with hearts hands and
brains vainly looking to our shores for
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness this is the grand political
rhetoric of course we expect to hear so
what we begin to hear of course here is
a the argument for land grant colleges
why do we need them and what we also
here is what their work is what their
job is what the consequences of their
jobs with the meaning and significance
of their work is and that is centered
mostly around economics but it also has
an ecological dimension there's a
historian from Yale named Stephen stole
he's written a really beautiful book
called the larding of the wiener
gorgeously written history it's a bit
traces the evolution of the
sustainability ethic in the 19th century
beautiful book so there's a presence by
the time he's making the statement some
really strong ecological thinking about
and many of you know this I'm sure
better than me the history of soil
science the history of this kind of
thinking yeah hundred years yeah yes
it's not saying exactly the same thing
she was saying but so so we start to see
this in his rhetoric but here's one
other little thing that he says I'll
just give you a little nugget of so what
I think what I think moral did is he
basically he painted a picture of what
was happening which was really was
almost all negative was really pretty
much all negative he then made this
prophecy of the doom that would bethe
which he used this really apocalyptic
phrases about skeletons and starvation
mass starvation everything and then he
said but he was the way we can fix all
that and and his answer this is somewhat
for those of you this all this mythology
about people like moral and the land
grant act ppl makes frankly they just
make stuff up about it it sounds good
but when you go back and actually read
what because everybody thinks yes he was
for education no he was for science
everything everything he was talking
about was the answer is science not not
education he talked about education that
but frankly it was about science but he
also said he liked everybody who's
complicated he said contradictory things
and he said a lot of things about
different stuff and here's one little
glimpse into that so part of what he
said is that government should aim not
only to elevate and build up a nation
that is great in its resources of wealth
and power but greatest of all in the
aggregate of its intelligence and virtue
he said that effort should be made to
satisfy and elevate the manhood and that
word was an italic of the mass of the
people statesmen and legislators he
wrote he said should aid to elevate the
class upon whom they learn first lien
for support and upon whom they depend
for their audience he also said that
every nation should not only be giving
should be giving all men must succeed
not only in giving all men quote an
opportunity by their own labor to obtain
a substantial support but also a higher
and possibly more difficult task which
is to combine the largest freedom with
the largest rewards of labor free
government and personal independence
something that moral argued was key to
securing quote the immortality of our
Republic so he's not just talking about
economics he's not just talking about
soil depletion and ecology he's talking
about something we would put have to put
under the category of culture political
culture political ideals so part of
making sense of these anecdotes is going
back and understanding the ways in which
the people who build these institutions
worked at these institutions who were
political advocates for these
institutions understand what they were
supposed to be about what their work was
supposed to be and we find in moral
science as the centerpiece of the
positive thing that would have to
contribute to the world but we also find
all this stuff about in those days there
was a gets into the weeds with political
theory but republicanism was the
political philosophy the public
philosophy that a lot of people worked
out of not democracy democracy was still
emerging as an idea that was seen
positively many of you may know that
Plato rejected democracy thought it was
a really terrible thing it was actually
asking the mob to rule which you know
was asking for mob rule so he rejected
that and the founders of this country
also rejected democracy they wanted
instead a representative Republic and so
they were grounded in this philosophy
that scholars refer to as republicanism
civic republicanism is one of the
strains of that moral was in that
category and so he he paid attention to
what he referred to as virtue and I will
say to you that this is one of the
reasons why the moral act
has the sentence in it that talks about
liberal and practical education for the
industrial classes that word liberal
signified that the education was not to
be narrowly technical or practical but
liberal and practical for reasons it had
to do with the understanding that we
need to be educating and helping to
create citizens in these days and a
republic not just technicians and here
is where my next piece and the history
comes in and I'm going to be done with
the history and this comes from Liberty
hi Bailey because there's this it's
situating these artifacts one historical
trajectory is this whole thing about the
land-grant institution and a lot sorry
one of the whole thing about soil
exhaustion about all the things that had
to do with bad farming and science was
was was the key is the key but the other
historical brand narrative that we need
to situate those artifacts in is a
narrative about oppression and freedom
and liberty and self-rule and the word
we use a lot today democracy and nobody
has spoken to this more eloquently and
concisely that i have found in the
period i'm looking at than liberty high
bailey and he did so in many places but
the most eloquently in his book that was
just republished last year for its
hundredth anniversary the holy earth his
1915 book there's a passage in that book
section in the book i think it's called
the democratic agriculture and the
democratic basis or something like that
I've erased out the header of that
here's what Bailey wrote in this passage
this again brings us some something into
view that is absolutely essential for
interpreting the median significance of
a farm bureau creed artifact and the
ruby green Smith artifact here's a
Bailey set for years without number four
years that run into the centuries when
men have slaughtered men
sorry when men have slaughtered each
other on many fields thinking that they
were on the fields of Honor when many
awful despotisms have ground men into
the dust the despotisms thinking
themselves divine for all these years
there have been men on the land wishing
to see the light tried to make mankind
here hoping but never realizing they
have been the pawns on the great
battlefield men taken out of the peasant
trees to be hurled against other men
they did not know and for no wards
rewards except further enslavement and
this next sentence goes right to Justin
moral in the land grant act they may
even have been developed to a high
degree of manual or technical skill that
they might better support governments to
make conquests then he says they have
been on the bottom upholding the whole
superstructure structure and pressed
into the earth by the weight of it so
here's Bailey in 1915 giving us a
sweeping view of thousands of years of
human history and the farmer the person
on the bottom the peasant the oppression
of that person used by governments used
by kings maybe even trained technically
in laboratories in universities and
colleges but then he he says and he's
telling a story or Bailey is doing a
grand prophetic narrative piece of work
here then he says the 19th century
brought a parting of the ways in the
United States that force hold the end of
this terrible story of the pression
narrative impression during this time
Bailey wrote farmers and others at the
bottom began to receive recognition not
only for their economic value of their
work but also in according to Bailey
most important way for their humanity
and dignity and their agency in standing
as citizens in his view this
multi-dimensional recognition was what
inspired the creation of the united
states department of agriculture in
nineteen eighteen sixty two land grant
colleges in 1862 agricole
experiment stations in 1887 and finally
the National Cooperative Extension
system in 1914 quoting Bailey quote a
new agency has been created in the
agricultural extension act which was
signed by President Wilson on the eighth
of May in 1914 a new instrumentality in
the world has now received the sanction
of a whole people and it almost staggers
one when one even partly comprehends the
tremendous consequences that in all
likelihood will come of it then he
conceptualizing extension work in
political rather than narrowly technical
terms he pointed that the problem of
relating quote in baileys words all this
public work to the development of a
democracy I am not thinking so much of
the development of a form of government
as of a real democratic expression on
the part of the people agricultural is
our basic industry as we organize its
affairs so to a great degree shall we
secure the results in society in general
and then Bailey went on to talk about
higher education and he said hi Rick
average occations engagement with
farmers needed to take the form of a
democratic Association that is deeply
educated for him it was imperative that
quote education should result or
function politically this is the ex Dean
of a college of Agriculture this college
of agriculture perhaps has an ex Dean
he's saying he said these kinds of
things when he was still the Dean it was
1915 education to result our function
politically with respect to the kind of
education that should be provided by
land grant colleges of agriculture
Bailey wrote and this goes right back to
Justin moral this is Bailey interpreting
the meaning and significance of the land
grant act of liberal and practical
education of his role as a scientist of
the role of others of his colleagues and
this institution this is what he's doing
is how I interpret what he's doing when
he wrote this it is not sufficient to
Train technically in the trades and
crafts and arts to the end of securing
greater economic efficiency
this may be accomplished in a despotism
and result in no self action on the part
of the people every democracy must reach
far beyond what is commonly known as
economic efficiency and do everything it
can to enable those in the backgrounds
to maintain their standing and their
pride and to partake in the making of
political affairs now if you can't hear
the Farm Bureau Creed's words resonating
in that quote if you can't hear what
Ruby green Smith said resonating in that
quote I'll go back and read them again
so we're discovering something here
that's really interesting that speaks to
these normative questions of the role
none of this is anti science none of it
none of this is against scientists doing
work in laboratories and Bailey was a
fierce defender of bass what we would
call basic research fierce defender of
that he pushed back very hard against
what he were thought of as the totally
irresponsible demand by politicians and
by the public that everything scientists
did at these institutions that have
immediate practical usability he pushed
back very hard against that because he
said every creation of knowledge is a
contribution to our Commonwealth and
other reasons why he was against that so
I got years of work I'm doing in
interpreting all this and tried to
develop this idea out of this history
and heritage of thinking at work going
back to the 19th century but it comes
into the present what I'm talking about
and that's what I want to so I'm going
to quote you for a second but the for
quoting you so I I in students and I
have done a lot of I become fascinated
with all of this not just as some thing
to read in the archives people who are
no longer living but wondering wow that
all of this is in the DNA of these
institutions I wonder if that's still
happening today I wonder if do we have
people saying some
our things who are scientists like
Bailey was or administrators what are
people how do people today talk about
their work what is the work that
scientists at institutions like Cornell
are doing when they're out beyond the
campus so we've been I've been spending
years doing these oral history
interviews finding engaged scientists
and inviting them to sell stories about
their work and experience about their
lives how they became an engaged
scientist so I published several books
of collections of these things with
analysis and interpretation one of my
favorites which is unpublished because
the Don world when we publish it yet is
a weed scientist one of your friends may
be named Don Weiss from the University
of Minnesota is anybody know down wife
you know that way so I just want to read
a couple of passages from his profile
which I which begins to help us move
beyond just kind of the idea of civic
science and but what does it look like
in practice what are the elements of
practice and civic science what a civic
scientists do what am i sup with that
one of the heck am I talking about
basically you know or would beyond some
philosophical thing that has grandiose
pneus to it so here's like two passages
i want to read from Don's profile and he
invited him to tell his life story how
did you end up as a weed scientist at
the University of Minnesota where did
you grow up so he grew up as a Mennonite
on a farm in Ohio raised by Mennonite
parents but he got all the way to the
place in his story where he was talking
about his getting the job at the
University of Minnesota so I read you
just a passage from from that when I
arrived here at the University of
Minnesota which was in 1974 when I
arrived here at the University of
Minnesota the position i got had two
obligations it was an 8020 split twenty
percent teaching so that meant I would
be teaching two courses my primary
responsibility in teaching was to teach
the undergrad weed management course at
that time the student population was
about 80 to 120 students the other
obligation which I found very intriguing
was the 80
% research I had no extension our
outreach component officially result the
research component was to work on
perennial weed management and grass seed
production in northern Minnesota
although I did have the opportunity to
work on perennial weed management and
other cropping systems statewide my
primary responsibility was to work with
a group of farmers in Roseau and Lake of
the Woods counties and a series of other
border kept bordering counties on
perennial weed management in legume and
seed production the University of
Minnesota College of Agriculture
specifically the Department of agronomy
and plant genetics had developed a
relationship with the area of the state
that goes back a number of years
probably back to the late 40s and early
50s there was a group of scientists from
the st. Paul campus who were breeding
grasses and leg and legumes it just so
happened that at the time some students
from northern Minnesota were attending
the st. Paul campus and had been taking
some courses and and learned about these
breeding programs and found that one of
the faculty had developed a series of
varieties of bluegrass I'm Way out of my
depth here talking about what he's
talking about so I'm just reading you
what he said one of them was called Park
Park Kentucky bluegrass in the
interaction that the faculty members had
with the students from that area of the
state they decided that they would try
some of these grasses in northern
Minnesota first the climate was ideal
for growth and development of Kentucky
bluegrass plus the community and the
students were interested in bringing
that crop to the area of the state
because of his risking the riskiness in
producing annual crops so in the late
40s relationships of developed and
Kentucky bluegrass seed production
started in that area my position was
created as a result of trying to expand
grasp legumes seed production in to
other species other than Kentucky
bluegrass now he talks about the problem
with expanding that the reason they
wanted that person to deal with that
problem had do with reducing the risks
then he says a group of farmers had
organized called the northern Minnesota
bluegrass producers they developed
around this initial opportunity created
by the University to produce Kentucky
bluegrass they then wanted to move
forward to create new opportunities they
had organized to ask the experiment
station and through the experiment
stations of legislature to create this
new position
his faculty position so it was pretty
well set up ahead of time that the core
group that I would interact with and
northern Minnesota was this loose-knit
group of seed producers when I
interviewed at the University of
Minnesota I interviewed not only on this
campus I interviewed him on the campus
but also interviewed with those farmers
and those farmers had direct input into
my selection so I didn't develop this
network I was brought in as part of this
network that had developed years before
my arrival I was brought in as one who
could fit into that philosophy and be
willing to work in that community and
help them develop these new economic
opportunities so here's a little glimpse
of the historical reality it's a little
moment in time one person's career as
I've researched across institutions
around the country this is in again in
the DNA of these colleges this
relationship here's a scientist whose
whole position is grounded and defined
in relationship to pacific place
specific people so what becomes
important is what is Don's work and
donna is a good friend of mine he was a
director of mesa the minnesota institute
for sustainable agricultural i was doing
my PhD in minnesota and he's a real
smartass joker and he has the habit of
always saying i'm just a weed scientist
but he's not just a weed scientist he's
he's fiercely engaged in the world and
in his field and the institution and you
know he's he's a philosopher he's a
civic educator he's all kinds of stuff
so I want to read one more passage brief
passage that begins to give us a glimpse
into his practice and it and I would I'm
naming this as Civic science you could
name it anything you want but I'm naming
it a civic science in with respect to
this whole set of discoveries that I'm
making and the tools i'm using to
analyze it so he's just giving us now a
little glimpse into what he does know
each spring we not just my project but
Nancy elke was reported one of his other
colleagues fly to northern Minnesota and
spend two days with the farmers and
other members of
community I need to emphasize that the
network of people that supports the
grass seed industry or university
personnel extension with in northern
Minnesota as well as bankers processors
and community members so it's a very
broad set of players who are active in
helping set the agenda and providing
leadership for the research and
education program each spring we get to
each spring in March we get together we
go through a two-day discussion which is
made up of presentations discussion and
future planning so the research agenda
that I carry out is not just my research
agenda it is a research agenda that has
been developed I would say even approved
by this network of people it becomes my
obligation to carry out that work in
partnership with them as well as to
report back to them help facilitate the
conversation around results and help
them provide the leadership for taking
next steps and the next series of
research questions which should then be
carried out to answer questions for that
community of course there's a wide range
of interest in that setting we have
individuals who want to sell inputs so
they would like to see cropping systems
develop that use of certain specific
inputs why so they could make a profit
selling those inputs such as herbicide
fertilizers etc we have a set of
processors and marketers who are
interested in getting seed from the
farmer to process charging the farmer
for processing and then taking the seed
and marketing it we have the farmers who
want to control the processing and want
to have a greater piece of the pie of
marketing so you have a full array of
interest it basically comes down to
facilitating this group of people in a
way that they continue to remember why
they are doing this work this work is
being done to add stability to that
community to really develop sustainable
systems so the conversations that we've
had over the years really come back when
these issues develop to remind them of
what we're trying to accomplish together
that's been part of my primary
responsibility I remind them why they
created these positions dr. Ellen's
position Nancy L Keys position and my
position in the first place I have told
them that and had that open up the
conversation it is a group that allows
that to happen I remind them that many
of them are are in that community
because of this relationship that has
developed between that community
community and the University of
Minnesota all of that came out when i
did when i said to don because i knew
him you're just a technician oh you your
weed scientist technician all you do is
you go out to the community with a
clipboard and you say what are your
problems what do you what do you need
what do you want and then you go back to
your lab and you just cook up the
answers and then you give them through
that's all you do I sometimes use this
strategy and doing interviews but only
if I build some level of trust because
it's disrespectful if you don't do that
but I knew I knew because I knew him
that that was not all he was doing that
he is not just a technician with a
clipboard and you hear it in what he and
his response he reminds them of why are
we here what are we doing he's conscious
of the differences in interests and for
God's sake this is the first time i
discovered that weed scientists were
civic educators that they knew that they
it's ingrained in him and it comes this
goes all the way through the history of
these institution and by the way none of
this is perfect it's deeply flawed Don
Weiss is not some perfection her heroic
figure up on a pedestal all of this is
imperfect it's in completely done it's
messy and all that kind of stuff but
what we see here is a practice of civic
science in which scientists and by the
way Donna's produce hundreds and
hundreds of published articles in the
top journals in his field and gotten
hundreds of millions of dollars of
funding so it's not a either you do this
stuff or you do the science not an
either/or it doesn't mean that Don does
everything you have partners who do
that's why you have the extension
facilitators in the local community
there's an ecology that's required to do
this Civic science work so now I want to
get into my closing here to just say out
of what I've I'm just in the middle of
this work so I'm sort of dumping out all
the stuff that I'm discovery and trying
to make sense of it in real time here
but certainly what emerges and this are
a set of challenges and questions that I
want a name very briefly the first one
of course that a lot of people named
when thinking about this this tradition
of work in land grant colleges is money
right capacity I've been at Cornell
since 1999 people like Heidi in the back
and and and others in this room can tell
you who have been here longer than me we
have lost faculty we have lost capacity
in this institution to work with people
in the state of New York they've lost it
in Minnesota they've lost it in a lot of
other states public disinvestment in
higher education has eroded the the
tradition of civic science of science
scientific work engaged with like Don's
work and Don tells a story about when he
started his job all the money he got
from the experiment station and it was
enough as he put it to run a show he
could run a lab he could open a lab up
on what I gotten any talks about how
today you don't get that so you got to
go to industry and that opens up a whole
set of challenges so money is an issue
it's a challenge public disinvestment
loss of capacity but this isn't just
about capacity and now I'm just going to
give you the tip of a very big complex
and deeply contest a deeply I want to
say controversial that its controversial
for a lot of people in different ways so
divisive well I don't know it's not just
about capacity it's about the way that
scientists are trained the political
influences on science and scientific
institutions there's a woman named
Stephanie Lee who is a development
scholar she's an anthropologist and a
lot of work in Southeast Asia she wrote
a book called the will to improvement
will to improve sorry I think it's
called a world home brew and she talked
about two practices that are central to
the realm of development work and by the
way land
aunt work his development work in the
19th century what they were doing is
they're trying to change the way farming
is being done and trying to change the
way people are eating change the way
people raising their kids its
development work right so there's two
practices she is identified in her work
both of which are anti civic science and
they're parallel there come their
companion practices one of them she
refers to as rendering technical and the
other one she refers to as rendering
non-political so to summarize a very
complex story what this means is you
come into a situation that is
multi-dimensional there's all kinds of
stuff happening like just think about
the two northern counties in northern
Minnesota that we got a glimpse of in
Don's message there's all kinds of
political and cultural and economic
things happening and this process of
rendering technical is to strip all that
out and say this is not a problem of
politics up here there's just a problem
of science of science technical science
and surprise when you do that it then
the technician is able to provide the
answer hey I got the answer for that if
you leave the politics and stuff in they
don't have the answer so when you rent
when you do this when you render
something technical when you render it
non-political you simplify it and we all
know this you simplify it too much you
have suddenly produced a real problem
and your intervention is going to be a
real problem this is this is I said this
is a divisive or controversial whatever
a lot of you know this is basically he's
pointing the finger at institutions like
our College and if you loo do the
history and stuff you can see the ways
in which the college if you know this
big expanse of thinking of Bailey Ruby
green Smith has flattened we don't hear
this kind of stuff anymore and in all
kinds of reasons why it's not just about
people being bad people this is a
complicated thing this is what we do in
my field is really trying to understand
that use robust tools to be able to do
that so that's another problem
there's another reality that's really
important is that we don't have very
good public cultures in these colleges
or in our fields for that matter a lot
of our a lot of what we do is based on a
theory of change bets we're making if we
do these things that this will happen if
we assembly in firm ation parents will
raise their kids better or eat better or
whatever and those theories of change
need to be subject to critical
evaluation how well is that working out
we don't have very good public cultures
in these institutions where we create
spaces to really engage around them or
to hold each other accountable for more
than just the technical piece and this
it takes time this pushes against
cultures in disciplines and fields
there's all kinds of reasons why this is
a challenge there's also a problem with
with overly ideological politics and
morally righteous politics which tends
to polarize these kinds of things here I
come right back to the election where I
started you know instead of instead of
creating a space where we can hear
across lines a difference and speak to
it respectfully but also critically we
have a we have a sort of zero-sum these
people are totally right and good and
these people are totally bad and evil
that is death to civic science because
citic science is really grounded here's
where my own bias comes in a more of
democratic populist politics so I'm
going to stop here that's a little
glimpse and all as I went too long and
I'm sorry about that well
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu